have a look at X how how could you make
a statement about X that has to do with
theta you're going to use the cosine
rule big flashing red light for the next
line the thing you're supposed to prove
has continent right so do you see what's
going do you see how the gears are
turning in my head I've got to get rid
of an X got a replace with a cos theta
what's the natural connection between
those it's the cosine rule does that
make sense so because if I show you
right now if I shown you this line here
will this working and you can go ahead
and give that's right come of this if
you like if I shown you this your
natural question would be certainly my
question is when I read a pair of set of
solutions what made you think to do that
what made you think to go there
immediately and the answer is I didn't
go there immediately I went through that
30 second thinking process that you
helped me through to work out this is
where I've got to go this is where I'm
coming from what is the most logical
connection and the answer is the cosine
rule okay so you can see once you've
identified all the right pieces it falls
out fairly seamlessly okay okay
just like before I promise I will come
back to this so you can take pictures
and what-have-you
I just wanted you to see the essence of
it and you can see I stated the cosine
rule I started with x squared is the
subject that makes the substitution to
here as minimal as possible because
literally x squared is equal to a
squared plus a why that's what I just
proved okay so now do you see that I
want you to think again about this
question let's get rid of all this fluff
I promise I'll come back again think
this is weird
this is weird we very seldom see
inequalities in the middle of geometry
question so your brain kind of weird a
little bit you know where do I begin
with this okay well how have I been
going through this so far to answer part
two what did I look at I look at Part
one to answer part three what did I look
at I'll loads in part two so the most
natural place for you to go to get
started on this a
is the immediately previous line so this
is a statement about why and then I want
to make another further statement about
why have a look at this what's
disappeared of here what's gone this guy
is gone right so something has to happen
with this something to do with in
inequality do I have any inequalities
that I know about that our relators to
cause you think really hard about this I
want you to track your mind back along
the last few topics that we've done
clearly the big thing in this whole
question is geometry that was the
immediately previous topic that we had a
look at right before a geometry crews
deductive proofs we looked at calculus
we did some Tonica is it's a calculus
question not to do calculus okay no
differentiation inside everything like
that what was before that trick well
that's a natural place to think about
some knowledge I want you to go back one
more step just for the sake of what was
before trig there was something we
learned that was a really important
foundation for calculus remember war was
faster than f functions right now
trigonometric functions are a really
important part of functions right
because they're very important thing
that you can do algebra with so think
back to functions think back to what you
know about trigonometric functions and
the inequalities you stated within that
you wrote hundreds of inequalities in
the functions topic what were they
talking about
you know how much I love this function
in the function topic you could tell me
where this function goes right where it
exists do you remember that was called
where this function exists you call it
domain and range what are the domain and
range of this function not a
photographer what what on it or values
of X for the range you know it's a
parabola so it's X is about a wires
above something okay if my memory seven
pretty sure its negative 1/4 but you of
course can find that out yourself okay
so have a look at this for a second
function function near inequality down
here yes okay oops
domain range not a rhetorical question
what's the domain of kha'zix it's still
overvalues isn't it what's the domain
that's sorry what's the range minus one
do one okay
think really hard think really really
hard look at what's being asked of you
okay you're trying to get to here from
here if this is true if Cod's X is
between negative one and one then it
stands to reason we scroll a little bit
can't go too far that cause of X will
cause a theater or cause of anything is
going to be greater than negative one do
you agree like that's the lowest it can
be you've got to be above that so if
I've doubled both sides in many ways in
many regards inequalities are just like
equations right we noticed this before
not always but a lot of ways so I can
tell Versailles do you agree with that
now why am i doubling both sides come
back have a look
why am i doubling both sides because I
don't actually have cause Theatre in my
inequality I am to concede oh they're
not so I double I slap a minus sign on
the front why that's like a minus sign
look again look at your question do you
see it's not actually to convict it's my
it's minus Q cos theta right that's what
I have but actually I don't have minus G
cos theta there's something else out the
front even there what there so what do I
do to both sides to put a 1 there
I should add 1 to both sides right that
looks suspicious dump into it don't burn
it
actually don't have just a 1 minus 2 cos
beta there's an a at the front isn't
there like you you prove that you prove
that we proved it together for the
previous loan but what is this what is
this thing here that's why now what did
i do what did i do that you didn't do
okay now to be fair because I've been
working with all of these topics for a
longer time okay every topic is kind of
like ah well actually since we did that
recently they kind of like points on the
circumference of a circle right of every
different point in mathematics links to
all the rest right and you get this
complicated web of relationships where
the more topics you get the more
interconnections you create okay and
what do we what do we call on here we
call on some deductive geometry because
we were proving that similarity right we
had to do some work with trig and this
last bit was calling on something in
functions which we hardly ever like you
probably think why don't we ever spend
all that time at that domain and range
well it tells you everything you need to
know about a function and where it can
possibly go but these are the only
pieces all of which you knew now that
you see it you're like oh oh that does
make sense but you just didn't think of
that combination before okay